[Musique]
je rentrais avec plein d'idéaux d'être
le chevalier blanc qui vient défendre la
veuve et l'orphelin qui va être utile à
la société qui va protéger les plus
faibles contre le fort qui va permettre
de mettre fin à des crimes et des délits
voilà la protection des gens et c'est au
fur et à mesure plus les années avancent
et plus j'ai vu l'envers du décor en
fait on n'est plus appelé à faire ses
missions là on doit faire du chiffre en
très du chiffre de la statistique qui
sont complètement déconnectés de la
réalité et de l'assentiment de sécurité
publique
après on nous a demandé de plus en plus
des mouches rail dans un service de
renseignement du renseignement sur des
choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec des
missions de police récemment nous a
demandé que pensent les gens des
discours de monsieur macron je veux dire
non en fait si vous voulez savoir ce que
pensent les gens du discours de monsieur
macron vous faites un sondage avec un
institut de sondage ce n'est pas la
police d'aller se renseigner pour faire
ce travail et donc on arrive sur ces
dérives ou en fait il ya une
instrumentalisation de la police d'une
dérive dans les missions de la police et
de son utilisation qui n'est plus comme
moi j'étais entré au service de la
population pour le bien-être général
mais pour des besoins de communication
on se sert de la police on la jette en
pâture ci a besoin
j'ai toujours essayé d'être à
l'intérieur pour essayer de réformer les
choses qui pouvaient se réformer de
l'intérieur et aujourd'hui c'est devenu
impossible malheureusement donc du coup
j'avais dit que le jour où ce serait
sans espoir de faire l'intérieur je
partirai de la police voilà on arrivé à
ce point de non retour
[Musique]
ouais
dans la police nationale on est
sanctionné non pour commettre des
violences il ya tout mouvement des
jeunes avec des personnes qui sont
mortes comme madame ginette day one il
n'y a pas eu de sanctions
on a eu la sphère steve castigneau à
nantes qui est ce jeune homme qui est
donc pour la fête de la musique qui a
été poussé dans la loire pareil qui est
mort il n'y a pas eu d'excusé a rien eu
de la part de la police nationale il ya
eu plus récemment monsieur cédric joue
via qui a été étranglée sur un contrôle
routier s'est dit que ça peut arriver à
monsieur ou madame tout le monde
de mourir en se faisant contrôler juste
pour un contrôle routier une plaque
d'immatriculation salle on parle pas
d'un terroriste du coup il ya toutes ces
choses là qui font que les
fonctionnaires qui sont ceux qui ont
commis ces exactions ne sont pas
forcément sanctionner ou ça prend
beaucoup de temps
al'inverse quand on est dans la terreur
à l'intérieur de la police nationale
quand on dénonce des dysfonctionnements
des dérives ont dit y ait des propos
racistes qui sont tenus il ya des
violences inadmissibles des ordres qui
sont illégaux et ben on se retrouve en
conseil de discipline
on se retrouve en conseil de discipline
pour avoir manqué à son devoir de
loyauté
on a en france une inspection générale
de la police nationale qui contrôle la
police vers la police se contrôler elle
même c'est une une
une exception dans les polices
européennes d'habitude c'est des organes
indépendants pour des raisons de
transparence justement et donc du coup
c'est à dire que là quand quelqu'un a un
problème avec la police
il va voir la police qui sous les ordres
du ministre et si jamais ça met en cause
un commissaire un préfet ou le ministre
évidemment l'enquète va vite est orienté
ou enterrés donc en fait il ya ce côté
qui était impossible et donc la loi
sécurité globale a rajouté le fait qu'on
ne peut plus filmer les policiers ou
alors si en prenant des risques
résultat des courses hier que le seul
dernier moyen de preuve de montrer ce
qui se passait en interne ne sera plus
possible et c'est ce qu'on a pu voir
dans la sphère à michel etc leur
monsieur michel déclassé la petite
goutte d'eau que moi qui m'a dit voilà
associations loi globale sécurité
globale michel éclair demain une action
comme ça se reproduit michel éclair sera
en prison pour avoir attaqué des
policiers alors qu'il sait louis qui a
été la victime dans l'histoire parce
qu'il n'aurait pas le droit d'utiliser
les vidéos qu'ils avaient pour diffuser
l'information et se défendre
[Musique]
jeudi à partir de là on ne peut plus
rien faire on est sanctionné arbitre m
en interne les moyens de preuve qu'ils
restaient les derniers c'est terminé
donc je me suis dit qu'à ce moment là
faut que je quitte la police nationale
parce que malheureusement il ya deux
méthodes de rester dans la police
nationale soit de faire comme j'ai fait
prendre un mandat syndical de parler de
dénoncer haut et fort les
dysfonctionnements soient l'averse
d'être très discret et d'essayer de
faire au mieux son travail est de rester
respecter la légalité et ces gens là il
a encore beaucoup dans la police
nationale française
heureusement mais au bout d'un moment
ils vont pas pouvoir tenir alors je fais
la petite aparté sais que c'est pas pour
rien que la police française à un taux
de suicide de 1 par semaine quasiment
parce qu'une perte de sens du métier un
malade un management délétères et que
rien n'est mis en place
la plupart des suicides des policiers ce
à cause de leurs conditions de travail
est la seule réponse du ministre a été
de mettre en place un numéro vert qu'on
appelle qu'on a le temps et quand on a
en plus grande détresse en plus grande
souffrance c'est pas ce mois là qu'on
appelle ce numéro de toute façon et dans
les faits le nombre de suicides n'a pas
changé donc en fait c'est cette
instrumentalisation de la souffrance
pour faire bien dans l'opinion publique
à côté de ça ça coûte des vies aux
policiers ce que les policiers meurt en
suscitant et c'est la première cause de
mortalité des policiers en service
malheureusement en france et à côté de
ça les la population ne se reconnaît
plus dans sa police aujourd'hui quand
quelqu'un voit un policier se dit qu'est
ce qui va me trouver
voilà je viens en caricaturant à
outrance les honnêtes citoyens ont peur
de la police et les délinquants et les
criminels on rigole et il ya des gens
violents qui rentre dans la police
nationale qui ne sont pas encadrées donc
le problème déjà et au niveau du
recrutement qui on recrute dans la
police nationale et pourquoi certaines
personnes vont passer le filtre à
l'heure actuelle sous depuis que
monsieur marc royer président le niveau
du concours de la police nationale est
passée à 8 de moyenne la première année
du quinquennat
la deuxième année qu'il n'y avait pas
encore assez de candidats qui
réussissait ils ont baissé le niveau du
concours ils sont quand même pris à 8 de
moyenne et on se retrouve avec des
élèves gardiens de la paix donc le
premier grade dans la police nationale
qui défraye la chronique dans une école
de police parce qu'il ne respecte pas le
confinement
ils agressent mais quasiment les
policiers qui sont chargés de la garde
de l'école dont je veux dire hostile et
jean demain qui seront policiers et la
police nationale française veut
tellement à voir des policiers sur le
terrain plutôt que de la qualité et de
la quantité c'est que ces policiers qui
sont à l'école de police ils consomment
du stup s'ils conduisent en état
d'ivresse
non pas de sanction pénale ils ont juste
des points en moins sur leur moyenne
dire quoi le but c'est de les faire
sortir quoi qu'il arrive
la plupart du temps et après quand il ya
un événement médiatique le ministre dit
moi je veux que les policiers soient
sanctionnés donc les attentes sont
conformes des commandes du ministre et
quelle que soit la raison le problème de
jivan ce n'est pas la vérité qui cherche
à faire plaisir aux autorités
supérieures